10 février 1970 une avalanche détruit un
centre ucb à val d'isère
des dizaines de personnes se retrouvent
prisonnières de la neige l'avalanche est
la plus meurtrière en france depuis 200
ans
elle fait de nombreuses victimes 39 au
total particulièrement des jeunes 37
personnes sont aussi blessées dans la
catastrophe
un grand souk qui à semer la panique
tout le monde s'est mis debout tout le
monde a cherché refuge au long des
parois du restaurant et puis ensuite
relais vitres éclatées et ça a été la
grande bousculade
à cette époque les domaines skiables se
développent les infrastructures se
multiplient
la catastrophe est alors polémique
pourtant l'ucp a écarté toute
responsabilité
tous les permis de construire déposés
pour val d'isère nous mentionner aucune
je dis bien aucune réserve
en ce qui concerne un risque quelconque
d'avalanche du côté des politiques
la catastrophe entraîne aussi une
véritable prise de conscience
seulement deux jours après le drame le
ministre de l'intérieur raymond
marcellin annoncé une série de mesures
au journal télévisé de nombreux efforts
d'athènes perd et surtout à mon avis les
efforts doivent être faits en ce qui
concerne l'implantation des bâtiments
il ya beaucoup de hardiesse actuellement
et il faudrait que cela soit
certainement modéré faudrait beaucoup
plus une étude
pourtant près de neuf mois après
l'avalanche meurtrière le centre ucpa
rouvre de nouvelles mesures de sécurité
ont été prises en compte à val d'isère
et par avalanche sont installés au flanc
des montagnes sous forme de râteliers ou
bien de filet on a aussi creusé des
tranchées construit des barrières pour
freiner les avalanches depuis ce jour
d'autres actions ont été prises pour
éviter de nouvelles catastrophes
par exemple la première carte française
de localisation des phénomènes
d'avalanche a été réalisé dès l'été 70
une association pour l'étude de la neige
et des avalanches
la nena a aussi été créé en 1971
[Musique]